[Music]
dear lord please give us the wisdom and
courage to make the correct decisions
today and always that will benefit the
people of this constituency and indeed
have influence worldwide give us also
the will and foresight to help plan for
the long-term future of all people near
and far we ask this in your name Amen so
good evening again members welcome to
this plenary meeting of the council
firstly I must advise members that from
7:30 p.m. this evening there is a
possibility that their Wi-Fi may be
affected due to a wireless controller
upgrade taking place this evening o
therefore do my utmost to ensure that we
conclude the business before then so I
think we probably will anyway may I
remind you all of some of the domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is also available in
the breakout air outside the meeting
room if the fire alarm should sound
please the read room by following this
fire exit signs and meet ellipse which
Town Football Club cleaning pitch do not
re-enter the building until you're told
it's safe to do so please switch off
your mobile phones or turn them to
silent I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except for
their confidential or exempt items if
you make a representation to the meeting
you will deep be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this room you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and all training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn it off again once you
finish will now move to the agenda
[Applause]
apologies for absence safety chair I've
received apologies from councillor
Creswell councillor Mabry councillor
McClaren and councillor Granger thank
you Oh counts award and also casts the
dorsum thank you declaration of interest
by councilors are there any declarations
item three BC 1926 to confirm the
accuracy of the minutes of the meeting
held on 22nd October 2019 for accuracy
only are there any uses with accuracy
fine thank you could I have a proposal
please counselor Osborn Adrien Osborn
could I have a seconder please
councillor Ward thank you all those in
favor that's curry thank you
item 4 BC 1927 to confirm the minutes of
the extraordinary meeting held on 22nd
October 2019 for accuracy only are they
an are there any issues with that
currency fine thank you
could I have a proposal please caps
award may I have a seconder councillor
Ayers thank you all those in favor
that's curry thank you
item six to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with council
procedure war rules Thank You chair
please be advised that we received
following validated petitions 111 valid
signatures regarding planning
application DC 1904 nine to three
amongst Ely and 22 valid signatures
supporting the following statement we
request that the bungalows numbered one
to two tapas field closed be restricted
to people aged 60 and above returning to
them to their original restriction of
residency to those of retirement age
those petitions have been dealt with
through the appropriate post process
thank you
yes I'm going to go back I live so we
will return now to item 5 BC 1928
announcement from the Chairman and
leader I refer you to paper BC 1928 for
noting thank you um now one of the one
of the other announcements I would like
to make is that many of you may remember
Len young who was a member of this
council for 12 years he was the member
for Glenwood and Stansted and
unfortunately he died very recently so
we'd like to pass his condolences as a
council to his family and friends and
express our sadness and regret it at his
passing so that's very sad news I I knew
him as well so that's one item I'd like
to mention and also as chairman I think
I've mentioned before that I'm having a
ball and so I do hope as many of you
that would like to do that kind of thing
and support the charities in particular
that I'm supporting they're all hardly
based charities because that's where I'm
from
and I hope I would love to see as many
of you there as possible it's on the
16th of May and you can buy your tickets
through Mandy so if if there's any
further information you want I can
provide that for you or Mandy can so I'd
be delighted to see you there are
limited tickets
now Cutts award have you anything to
report please yes Thank You Janet
just before Christmas and I think
probably many of you may have missed it
Peter Garrick sent out a very
informative update on what it has been
done by the public realm team and the
extensive range of day-to-day activities
that the team undertakes
Peter also said that team will be
offering Ward tours to enable members to
see the team's work at firsthand in
their wards the things that the team
does have a direct and highly visible
effect on the quality of residents lives
and there is a growing interest in the
management of our open spaces for
well-being and the environment our
proposals for tree planting and by duck
and biodiversity corridors will also
mean working directly with our
communities Peter also mentioned a new
five-year program of play site
improvements so please contact Peter to
arrange a tour and discuss improvements
you would like to see in your wards I'd
like to take this opportunity
opportunity to congratulate the Thomas
Gainsborough school on behalf of the
council for becoming the first school in
Suffolk to be accredited as a heritage
school this is in recognition of the
work that students and also teachers put
into the sub research stories project
and it is something that the whole
school and community can be proud of
last Friday councillor John Osborne and
I visited the Sudbury Food Bank run by
the vineyard church we were told how the
food bank operates and discussed the
increasing demand that it is
experiencing it was a very productive
meeting which identified some good ideas
about how Baber
can work with a voluntary sector to help
reduce the need for who for food banks
but also how we can also provides some
practical help for rough sleepers and
these will be discussed with officers to
see what we can actually do next week
there will be two days of consultation
at San Peter's Church and Sudbury on
several key aspects of our vision for
the town we will be presenting the
results of a survey conducted by WSP on
behalf of Suffolk County Council and
ourselves into the relocation of bus
stops and public realm improvements to
the market Hill there will also be a
presentation of the four proposals we
have received for the reuse of Bellevue
house ideas further improvements to the
park and also an update on the plans for
a hotel and restaurant
all members are invited to attend a
preview for members and sub retail
counselors on Wednesday morning and
finally just a reminder that Kate
Parnham has sent out an email about
mandatory equality and diversity
training there are still some members
who are yet to attend and further dates
will be announced soon this is actually
a very good and enlightening session and
I do recommend it thank you Jim
Thank You councillor Ward so we'll move
back on to number number seven now
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedural rules thank you
madam chairman just the point on item
six you said about 22 signatures for
topless feel close in confirm that is in
Hadley please thank you
[Applause]
now we're on to item eight questions by
councillors in accordance with council
procedure rules Thank You chair none
received thank you
now we're going to the main body of
today's meeting to receive reports from
cabinet members it's my intention to
limit discussions of this item to 30
minutes I will therefore draw the
questioning to a close after 30 minutes
has elapsed if the item has not been
concluded I would like to invite
councillor Ward to introduce this item
thank you
thank you chair in front of you you'll
see the latest cabinet reports from
members of the cabinet and as previously
you've got all reports in front of you
if you have any questions then you can
the cabinet members are here to answer
those questions
what I would like to say at this point
that this is the last time that these
reports are going to be presented in
this format what we are proposing to do
is to enhance our quarterly cabinet
reporting in the future to include more
narrative and also aspects of Finance
and risk and to beef those up as opposed
to having these these reports in this
format so in future the the best way
then would be to look at the cabinet the
gender packs and come along to cabinet
meetings and ask questions directly then
Thank You chair thank you
write C mu 10 cabinet member for us it's
investments are there any questions
my questions fine and we'll move on oh
[Laughter]
okay we take it have a question Kelso
Lindsay thank you very possibly savagely
sorry thank you I wasn't going to ask
anything but I thought I kicked I did
half face no oh it's just it just
occurred to really reading it for and
talking about trying to beef up the ball
engage shopping center and you've got
the it's a cool next to it the other
development retry that at Babel owns
have you look to have we as a council
look to some things old chin chin has
done for example where they they had a
similar covered arcade they converted it
into a food hall and that became a big
draw brought in lots of football for the
town and is seen as the anchor piece for
that town and and they actually
triggered a recovery in the number of
shoppers because at the moment it seems
like we've got these units and we feel
we have to fill those units and that's
it but maybe some blue sky thinking you
could get rid of all units and have some
kind of marketplace food or something
like that
yeah it's just something I thought I'd
throw in I can't possibly answer that
thank you right Sudbury needs something
point to direct people in six bits that
you know the beauty of the town whether
it's a shopping mall or whether it's
something else I think we're still
working on those things and hopefully
over the next three months you will see
quite a bit of progress on the direction
that Sudbury needs to take so yeah
what's his face it gets customer-facing
was a question that you heard point of
information
mmm-hmm I actually lived in or Chingam
and the building you talk about wall is
a listed building it was the original
market for all during ham it was a
covered market and what they've done by
make creating a food hall is in fact
going back to their roots because that's
what it was it was a place where you
bought your food and was a place where
food was also cooked so it's slightly
different than Boram Gate thank you
thank you any further questions from
this paper
[Music]
fine we'll move on then C mu 11 camera
number for communities any questions
coming into just a quick one around
chairman really on point three point one
of the CMU 11 the grants teams conducted
site visits to discuss accept etc to
read what's what's on there when how I
are there likely to be any decisions
relating to those visits and those
applications for grants oh I don't have
a definitive answer for you obviously
once the work has been completed and a
full assessment has been made then
they'll come forward I'll find out for
you and I'll get back to them any
further questions to the member for
communities can't suppose be a three
point for you talk about these to teach
you treasurer advisor that's been
working with the grants team Football
Association to develop this local
football facility plan I understand that
the person the question is coming to the
end of their appointment and I just
wonder whether there's a contingency for
carrying on afterwards because I don't
think we all got to a position where the
decision would have been made no I
believe that will we all go and I
understand that
the application has to be made by
mid-february and but that will be
carried on you yeah applications various
individual applications have been made
one in February you're so new God
wouldn't in this room but also
understand mid Suffolk you've got the
same any further questions
oh right yes please
and so I don't have a question for
myself but I would like to take the
opportunity of welcome communities new
corporate director who's in the route
are Vicki Bo's they say welcome to the
team
I'm sure she's gonna be make it be
invaluable asset to its all of us thank
you if they're in it oh yes counselor
can I just comment on the completion of
the work at the Kingfisher leisure
center in Sudbury which is now reopened
with new facilities I have attended
classes there and they're absolutely
full you can't actually get into them
there is must be more scope for running
classes is there do you think there is
you know there is someone who is
ensuring that they get the absolute best
out of those new facilities don't keep
them waiting
thank you for that and I'll pass that on
to our partners are bencroft leisure who
have done an excellent job along with
our team in making sure that the work
was done it hasn't been easy we've had a
few bumps in the road but as you say
that the end result is fantastic and
it'll be the same when we get
sadly as well as we're progressing now
I'll find out for you to make sure that
the management is up to scratch with all
of these things there's always little
things we can make better a great
partner and I'm sure that will happen
and I'm sure we've got Tom and Vickie
here and Cassandra that will make sure
that thank you very much
just a quick one of interest really more
than anything else at 3.2 it talks about
an increase in the number of calls by
about 9% what are we doing that means
that people have got to ring us up more
often why people ringing us as anybody
looked at why they're ringing us rather
than just whether we're satisfying them
or how long it takes to answer the call
because I know that when I have called
the call center in actual fact we didn't
get I didn't get a satisfactory answer
could I was told the person they would
have to take a message and pass it on
and the message was passed on apparently
but never answered Thank You counselor I
don't obviously have the specific data
as to what those calls will relate to I
think it's probably reasonable to say
that as a digital transformation
continue then we're encouraging more
people to contact us by various methods
but there are there all sorts of reasons
possibly seasonal why calls may increase
so I don't honestly know what the reason
for that 9% is I will endeavor to find
out and come back to you counselor if we
might just just a point out of the
course of here we're talking about calls
meaning telephone calls not digital as
in going to the website so it's not an
increase in digital activity it's an
increasing non digital activity any
further questions I think if I could
assist just in relation to other
question we had a fairly major election
in that period of time which did prompt
a lots of phone calls in relation to
making sure people on their register cuz
as you know if they had an interest in
making sure that they voted and people
can't always do that online there does
sometimes require a phone call so I
suspect although I wouldn't like to
speculate entirely that that may have
been a significant change to our normal
if you like in terms of the x levels of
call volumes that we would expect okay
we'll move on to the next paper CMU 13
Kevin remember for economic growth any
questions
come sir Oh Ansari right yeah thank you
and I've noticed the bit in the 3 and
3.6 3.6 where we have continued to work
with major employees including the
Delphi site have you got any more
information on that place in answer to
your question no not at the moment we
will obviously continue dialogue with
Delfy it's been extremely difficult
dialogue in that they haven't been fully
willing to engage but we continue to do
that and we will obviously notify
members as of when we get some
information on that but at the moment we
have no more updates any further
questions
councillor Hinton thank you about
chairman hmm yes also on looking at
three point six we're talking about also
supporting developers who are bringing
forward new sites in our area such as
the five hundred thousand square feet
opportunity in Brampton well that's the
the old model story site which of course
has been sitting there for some time now
but what about the site at the top of
the hill in Hadley than persimmon
solders for five pounds or whatever it
was so that they could build on the rest
of the site are we looking forward to
developing those sites or bringing
forward somebody to develop those sites
because it's not mentioned in here
anywhere and we don't have a very good
reputation or outcome rate if you like
in terms of encouraging new businesses
into the area or team to have Sarika
incident was that the land at the top of
the persimmon site yeah yeah
we will come forward with some options
on that site as and when we have them
available and we'll bring it to members
and bring it to cabinet and they'll be
discussed the poem but until we've got
the information I can't really comment
on that other than what you say any more
questions
cut sir Norman
thank you manage them and I just spoke
to asked and three-point-eight you've
mentioned that there's large empty units
and cob dogs which I assume or you're
referring to there is the old Toys R Us
site and just wondering as you mentioned
that there is some consider some
potential new tenants in there I know
that they were talking about that in
regards to the Taylor Taylor Wimpey
we'll see great new development and as
something might be happening there so I
was just wondering if you had any
updates with regards to that at all
so was that just to the popped up one
yes no again we're working with agents
and other bodies to try and attract new
businesses to them and really at this
stage we can't really comment other than
that we are open to dialogue with agents
and as I say companies that are looking
to bring their business to copper up and
move about Mothercare now they can as
well so we've got in the house of yeah
so there are several units up there
which they are conscious of but we are
in dialogue with agents to try and get
them filled as quickly in as best as we
can
any further questions fine
so we'll now move on to CMU 14 cabinet
member fun environment are there any
questions no questions we'll move on
then Oh counselor Hinton yes just
basically on the civic civil parking
enforcement I gather that my my contacts
tell me that they can't actually enforce
anything until all the white lights have
been made or parking restrictions have
been made legally compliant in other
words the right distribution of signs
the right distribution of lines and tees
at the end of them and all the rest of
it which is a gatherer County Council
responsibility before they hand it all
over to us when is that likely to happen
but you haven't seen a lot of activity
in terms of repainting white lines other
than Essex who are repainting the white
lines down the middle of the road on the
137 so they can then dig it up again
when they fill in the potholes don't
smell Phase II are you able to help on
this um I thank counselor Hinton through
his question it's actually ongoing I
have seen things in Sudbury being white
lines painted yellow boxes and yellow
lines so County is on it but I will
chase them up on your behalf okay thank
you any further questions fine
so we'll now move on to CMU fifteen
cabinet member for finance any questions
the new questions will move on see a new
16 Legion cabinet member for Lauren
governments any questions any questions
CMU 17 cabinet member for housing are
there any questions
cutter Osborn needs to present my
quarterly housing report to lenders as
members can see a great deal of work is
taking place within the housing team to
ensure that officers provide a
supportive and fit for purpose service
by coming up with creative and
innovative ways policies and working
practices as well as maximizing funding
all under very challenging and emotive
circumstances I am very conscious that
members need to be kept informed of
these new policies and changes etc and
with this in mind I am having
discussions with officers on the best
way of achieving this once agreed I will
it be advising all members of what these
arrangements are just to add that in
addition to my shadowing officers in the
housing solutions team on Tuesday last
week I visited our operatives working on
voids and responsive repairs I visited
four sites and met eight operatives
varying in age and experience and it was
a really interesting experience and a
good way of spending a day so I'm now
happy to take questions madam chairman
thank you Thank You Councilwoman
counselor beer thank you madam chairman
my question to the cabinet member for
Harrison I do know that you've got her
on - sorry 3 1 regardin the
neighborhood's teams focus on the state
management as you know stood up in this
chamber recently and complained about
the bad carryings-on on our state's
council house estates on the greens
wards and the verges and what-have-you
and I have seen that we've sent in an
enforcement officer he's certainly been
in the corner can you give us any update
of how he's getting on and whether he's
going to be gone during the hold of the
district I believe he was hoping that
there was going to be some support to
help him thank you thank you councilor
beer for your question
yeah the neighborhood team is a very new
team and we're currently in the process
of recruiting to that team there is no
feedback at the moment because it is in
its early days once I get the feedback I
will report back to you as well but also
just to add to that councillor Davis and
myself have I had several meetings with
police now from both sides of the
district on ways that Weber can work
with the police to ensure that not just
our housing developments but throughout
the area that people live in a safe
community and that their quality of life
is improved we are planning to hold
facilitated by both Bebo and the police
services a briefing for members a
workshop so that we can brainstorm and
bring ideas together and that should be
happening sometime in February any other
questions
councillor Hinton thank you my chairman
yes the development of the business case
for joint venture for the future
delivery of building services can we be
assured that any joint venture that is
put together does have a quality
assurance aspect to it because I have to
reluctantly report that one of my
residents had elderly residents had a
problem with the boiler which broke down
which was a considerable delay despite
this cold weather before somebody came
out to fix it they fixed it 24 hours
later it broke again and there was a
further delay before somebody came out
to fix it and 24 hours after that it
broke again
it is finally working but after a
considerable period of intermittent hot
water supply and cold weather it's not
good for the older population to be
suffering in that way so we need
something that's going to make sure that
the repairs that we make stay repaired
rather than being just temporary budgets
if you like to keep things moving I can
assure you that will happen as part of
the possible new venture is only an
option at the moment it's been
investigated however away from that
we're still working on our building
services to make sure that there's a
good and effective service alongside
looking at the options for the joint
venture with flagship blue flame is very
much part of that and then we're
currently undertaking a review of blue
flame who carry out the repairs to
boilers etc so it's not only going to be
done as part of that investigation into
that possible venture it's also being
done alongside that as a day-to-day
process thank you any further questions
fine
we'll move on now to stem you 18 cabinet
member for planning are there any
questions
telsa beer thank you thank you madam
chairman first my friend the cabinet
member for planning whether it's
possible that members of the planning
committee could have copies of the
latest to neighborhood plans in a hard
copy thank you yeah I'm not quite sure
if it's question on the report but the
answer to you is yes of course they can
okay it is available obviously via link
but if you want a hard copy you can have
a hard copy any further questions
councillor him thank my chairman looking
at three point five relation to planning
enforcement we have been notified just
recently there is going to be a review
of planning enforcement I hope that all
members will be involved in that
particularly the the planning committee
because it does
have a few questions to answer and I
think it's partly a question of
resources and partly a question of
management I don't know yes there is a
review of both enforcement and heritage
and he's not here this evening but
perhaps Tom could pass on my thanks to
Phillies Bell because she's done no I
know Tom's here but feel business
perhaps Tom could pass on my thanks to
Phil his Bell for all the work that he's
doing we're making progress it's gonna
take a while John but yes the review is
ongoing and it's it's already started
can I just add the counselor intern
satisfaction that is actually on the
scrutiny agenda for this next month's
meeting and we've had active discussion
with Phyllis Bell to determine what
should be in that report to address I
think concerns that many members have
been asking of us for well as long as I
have been on the council so yes it is
going to be a comprehensive review at
least as far as I can tell thank you any
further questions thank you so this is
complete oh yes you reckon through those
so quickly chair that I've missed the
opportunity to ask a question on CMU
fourteen this on four point for the tree
for life schemes gonna close at the end
of last year and now comes input look at
distributing the trees he says the to
distribution sessions are being
organized for Jan and Feb 20 20 and you
give us more information on that because
my granddaughter qualify apologies and
the Bieber one I think is the first of
February at Kendall Shum Village Hall
yeah but I don't think that's in the
report but now that you mention it we
had a hundred a total of 170
applications which equals 23 percent of
births and adoptions in Baber
I think so thank you I think we can now
complete this section will now move to
item 10 BC 1929 overview and scrutiny
committee report I would like to invite
councilor McCraw to introduce his report
which is for nating Council McCall Thank
You chairman and I apologize for not
having that ready I was so busy going
back to CNU 14 right I don't propose
you'll be very pleased to hear to go
through the report in any detail because
I think it speaks for itself and it has
been widely distributed through all
people involved the members of the
cabinet full members of the council as a
separate document because well we
thought this is quite important this is
the only thing I'm bringing forward to
as a scrutiny report today because of
the general election but I can tell you
that we have already met three times
this months as a scrutiny committee
either in joint or single session so
we're doing our best to do our catching
up and I will have a substantial amounts
to report to in February but this here
now is the final result the final report
on our recommendations which you'll find
at the end of the report as far as this
council is concerned those
recommendations in many ways were
already underway and under consideration
effectively we were pushing here at
least at an open door and I'm glad to
say that the cabinet of Barbara have
already decided at the recent cabinet
meeting they've had to this month that
the necessary review that we recommended
could be carried out by a scrutiny
committee on an annual basis and I'm
happy to accept that as a good idea
so you have the basic report there we
have hoped that this would read
a resource a piece of material to a
study if you like to inform people not
just for now but for the future and we
wanted it to be a document shared with
as many as possible sorry to say at the
moment it doesn't appear to have
achieved a positive response from
Suffolk County Council as was reported
at the weekend but then again it's early
days in some ways budgets have not yet
passed and maybe other things could
result I'm happy to take any questions
on the report are there any questions to
custom occur all thank you thank you it
cuts illumines ii oh sorry
Coates Rossi it's just a quick question
really I was just looking through here
to see if I could find what I think you
said which was that you will continue to
look at this on an annual basis is that
right yes thanks counselor Aarthi at the
point of the writing of this report that
cabinet meeting had not taken place our
recommendation was that we're multi-year
deals were involved with funding
authorities they'd be subject to a
three-year rolling and with a system
with an annual review and an
inflationary amount increase this was
something and decided subsequently but
as I say we're happy to accept that
point I would it have helped if the
Suffolk County Council of scrutiny
committee had been had taken part in in
this process and if so how will you try
to encourage them to play a full part in
future
I think you redress a very important
point this is a something that's not
often attempted across authority
scrutiny process in this instance for
authorities were involved ourselves mid
Suffolk obviously had already looked at
it we were joined by West Suffolk and
Ipswich Borough Council East Suffolk and
Suffolk County Council were of course
both invited myself and Keith Welland
the chair of the mid Suffolk overview
and scrutiny committee made approaches
to various members but obviously going
through the chairs as would be
appropriate in those instances they felt
unable to take part for one reason or
another I regret that because we found
the process valuable all the members
involved and it's interesting to note
they were cross-party they were also
cross Authority we represented all five
of the major political groups in
operating in Suffolk and this is a
Suffolk question it is not as something
just there is Suffolk County Council's
and it's not just the districts it's all
of us so in any subsequent event yes we
would definitely encourage them and we
hope in fact we've demonstrated that it
was an open process and perhaps not and
not the closed-minded approach that they
may have feared I think we demonstrated
that we did a rather better job than
that thank you any further questions
Oh celts award it is not really a
question it's it's more of an
observation on the first two
recommendations about the amounts that
you're recommending Suffolk County and
the civs contribute I'm concerned that
you've got specific numbers in there
rather than just a general feel that
we're where possible or if possible at
some point in the future budgets allow
that they seek to to review their
contribution levels rather than putting
in specific targets like this which i
think is we know is it's difficult in
the case of Suffolk County Council to
achieve and we all know that their
budget is is very difficult at the
moment so I think that that would
probably be
if the recommendations have been phrased
along those lines I think to answer that
question the general point was of course
that we were not specifically making
recommendations to an authority that was
not a constituent part of the group we
make that point obvious in the report
and I might add in when we sent the
report on to Suffolk County Council we
recognized that we had no formal
reporting powers to them our formal
reporting powers were to our own
constituent councils and that was the
approach we took however it would have
been ridiculous to have done this work
and made these points so the figure
isn't represented in a and B have
represent what had previously been
provided by Suffolk County Council two
years ago we used that as a baseline and
considering the difference would be from
120,000 that has currently proposed
184,000 we are talking six to four
thousand pounds a year it is not a large
amount
perhaps in the context of Suffolk County
Council's budget but we recognize that
that is a matter for Suffolk County
Council and we're not you know we're
making a suggestion you can call it a
recommendation but the figure is a
sensible figure and of course it
restores a baseline that previously
existed that was the reason for the
figure any further questions
okay we'll move on to our next item now
item 11 BC 1930 Oldham neighborhood
development plan I would like to invite
councilor Aarthi to introduce paper BC
1930 and to move the recommendations and
report
council I see thank you yeah
I'm delighted to bring the old note of
the plant to you today for adoption
those of you that know of them will know
that it's one of our smaller villages
and it's got just 166 on the electoral
rolls so this is the smallest
neighbourhood plan that we've seen come
to us and I applaud the time and
commitment given by all those involved
in the village it is a concise plan it
focuses on housing development that is
proportionate to the village as a whole
and seeks to ensure essential
characteristics of the village it
allocates to sites small sites one for
seven dwellings that's already got
planning permission and one for five it
includes a policy that supports
affordable housing on rural exception
sites and a policy that allocated pump
green as a local green space paragraph
43 sets out the format of the question
asked of those entitled to vote and the
results were the total number of votes
67 which was a 40 percent turnout the
number of yes votes was 61 which is 91
percent with only six no votes that's
nine percent and I commend the
neighborhood plan to you and ask you to
endorse the recommendation that we
formally adopt I think you can't slothy
can I have a seconder please councillor
beer I can open this up to questions and
debate would anyone like to discuss
anything with this
oh yes thank you yes thank you madam
chairman
yeah just like to say actually a lot I
passed my gratitude actually to the
chairman of Oldham Parish Council for
actually communicating with me as a
neighboring councilor at Suffolk County
Council anyway
very to bring this neighborhood plan to
my attention so I'm grateful for that
thank you
Thank You councillor Fraser anyone else
would like to speak on this matter
thank you cut sir Arthur's everything
else you'd like to add thank you
in that case we'll put it to a vote
those in favor that's unanimous thank
you we'll move on now to item 12 BC 1931
decision taken by the chief executive
during the pre-election period under
delegated powers in accordance with part
2 of the Constitution I would like to
invite Council Aarthi to introduce paper
BC 1931 which is for noting over the
perler period that we were talking about
earlier on so the eight-week statutory
period for the council to adopt the plan
fell during a period where where we
couldn't do that so my thanks goes to
the chief executive Arthur for doing
that during that period and the officers
involved in in enabling that to happen
called Brian particularly is there yes
thank you Paul just follow on with
similar information to the Oldham 1 the
referendum for Elms that was held on the
7th of November the results to that were
a total number of votes cast of 312 a 47
under half percent
a lecture 656 in Helm's it the number of
yes votes was 292 which is 93.6%
and the total of no votes was just 20
which is 6.4 percent the elms that plan
provides for around 60 dwellings to be
built by 2036 41 are expected to come
forward on an allocated site that
already has outline permission the
remaining dwellings are expected to come
forward on small windfall sites and
infill plots mmm again announced that
they've designated local green space
seven local green spaces and a special
character area the adoption of the plan
in December and of Odom's today which
you've just adopted brings the total
number of adopted neighborhood plans in
Baber up to five currently there are 24
other parishes this is a rise on my
report which I gave you earlier on which
I think quoted 22 pitch um is one of the
new ones and I don't think of the other
so there are now 24 other parishes in
Weber working on neighborhood plans the
figures include lavender Mandy's burger
who've already adopted plans but are now
looking to modify and update these
particularly with regard to the emerging
joint local plan there is on the bottom
here a message which I wanted to give to
all of you and anybody else who's
listening over them over the interweb
and that is that those people bringing
forward neighborhood plans should focus
on the land-use planning issues that are
important to the community be realistic
about how they can contribute to the
wider need for new homes and through the
neighborhood plans be able to add value
at the local level thank you
Thank You councillor RC are there any
questions
any questions Celso Lindsay thank you
she wasn't a question it's just just to
because it's not actually my elm cir
handle de mer in my county council
division and actually I used to
represent them at the district level as
well some time ago but just to sort of
congratulate the village of the
communities themselves or in the parish
councils for going ahead with this and
now onset had felt they were kind of
under siege from developers there's all
kinds of three applications going on all
over the village and the reason they
they brought this forward was exactly I
think the right reasons that they could
they wanted to development but he wanted
to be able to have some say and make
sure he went in the right areas not the
areas that they wanted for open space
and so on so I think both villages have
done a good job and done it in quite
particularly ohmsett it was quite a mess
so they got on with it quickly because
there a lot of developers hovering and
they've already been using it even
though it hasn't been until today voted
on they've been using it to influence
developers and say well our local plan
doesn't allow that so we're gonna resist
that so I'd not only would I commend
these local plans but I
I commend other villages to who are
field similarly threatened to to get on
with major plans
thank you Thank You counsel Lindsay
Council Parker thank you
yeah I'd just like to echo councillors
these words said madam chair we're
starting to see a large number of these
plants coming forward unfortunately all
of the villages within my ward of
undertaken this and I think that we
should recognize the extraordinary
amount of volunteer hours that is
undertaken by members of our community
and engaging with this process and I
think maybe
nothing but praise certainly from from a
planning committees point of view we've
had examples of decisions that we've
been able to say because neighborhood
plans exist and I suspect it's going to
make our life a lot lot easier so I've
got nothing but praise and applaud
anyone that's involved in the process
thank you Thank You councillor Parker
any other yes cuts the Barrett can I
just ask make a general point and
question really on on the neighborhood
plans because I think that there's been
quite a few communities who have
undertaken this now and I'm sure they
feel very much in the dark when they
first set out on this and need quite a
bit of support from their council
officers do capsule officers now have a
really good system in place to do that
and have they learned from the process
from when it was first sort of embarked
on so they can deliver a very young sort
of productive and supportive role to the
communities slothy I don't want to put
him on the spot
but I wondered if Paul wanted to comment
on that Paul is is sort of the man who
who is engaging with all of these
communities and ensuring that they
follow due process and has been involved
in these plans coming to us for adoption
Paul are you would you be happy to just
say a couple of words on that
it is an iterative process and we've got
something original 5252 neighborhood
client or parishes working on
neighborhood plans or have plans adopted
and they do talk to each other and we do
encourage them to talk to each other a
lot of the initial part of the process
around grant funding and how groups can
go about getting that it's something
that we don't get involved in that
relationships between the groups and
locality who responsible for making that
money available are for government so
yes we we're learning lessons all the
time and the we have a number of
consultants who are preparing neighbor
plans they're learning lessons all the
time from the examiner's reports they're
making sure that those lessons are
implemented in plans that have come
forward at future dates and yeah it's
it's really about encouraging the groups
to talk to themselves as much as
anything share their experiences whether
in a helpful way and hopefully we all
get what we wanted in their plan that
works for everyone thanks Paul for that
and I forgot what I was thanking people
earlier on I thanked Paul I thanked
d'Arthur because of course they were
involved in making sure this was adopted
in the due time but I didn't thank you
because of course you were involved as
well and I presume you had to come in on
the 10th of December to sign the
paperwork so thank you very much as well
any further questions
and I presume you have nothing else to
either counsel Aarthi thank you
well in that case we'll take that report
as noted and thank you for it and that
really brings our meeting to a close now
the date of the next meeting is when you
stay 26 of a February and that effect
5:30 so look forward to seeing you all
then and I call the meeting closed at
6:35 apologies members my papers I've
been giving some rather incorrect papers
yeah silence please everybody there's
been a few problems with my papers so
Rick we're now going but I'm having to
reopen the meeting again and item 13 has
been left off so we're going to go back
to the paper again and I apologize for
this counselor appointment so we just
need to agree the following appointments
to outside bodies paper domestic
violence and abuse forum counselor Mary
McClaren the Suffolk violence and abuse
partnership counselor Mary McClaren the
Suffolk health and well-being board
councillor Derrick Davis
so can we take a vote on these
appointments as a group please all those
in favor please
thank you that's carried so now we can
close the meeting so I apologize for
that error and the meeting is now closed
thank you